nasa's first step toward returning to
the moon monday morning the space agency
plans to launch the artemis rocket from
florida's kennedy space center it stands
322 feet tall and is the most powerful
rocket nasa has ever built the launch
will be without a crew on board a test
flight around the moon and back if all
goes well the space agency says it could
have astronauts walking on the moon
again in the next few years mark
strassman is at the kennedy space center
with more mark good morning
good morning dana yeah if it flies on
monday it really ought to be something
to see you know in its purpose and
technology and his personnel
artemis is a very very different
dramatically different than the apollo
era ever was but the closer you look the
more connections you'll see
it's gotta be one of the most proud
moments of my life to wander is to
wonder
apollo's spectral images of space
wanderers moonwalking helped define the
20th century
fast forward a half century artemis
nasa's first attempt to return people to
the moon where do you start you just
dust off the old apollo manuals
you know a lot of our guys did the guy
rick lebron artemis one's lead flight
director took us inside the old apollo
mission control by today's standards
nasa reached the moon using paltry
technology analog everything rotary dial
phones and slide rules it's kind of
mind-boggling when you think about it so
we're all set for op nav this is the
artemis mission control in houston no
one working in here lebron included has
ever worked on a moon shot that could
carry astronauts the launch is game time
it's going to be very different and you
know
you hear the pucker factor it'll be
there
also there on launch pad 39b in florida
the sls rocket it stands 322 feet tall
nasa's most powerful rocket ever at
liftoff firing nearly 9 million pounds
of thrust this is the orion mock-up on
top the artemis crew capsule called
orion you have room for four people
rather than three people with apollo
correct we're going to take four people
back and forth to the moon and we are
also intending to fly those four people
for longer periods of time
another big difference nasa's moonshot
team for apollo 11 white guys wearing
white shirts and skinny ties
one woman in the room the lone exception
you look out at our team and it is a
different makeup and that's a great
thing ntd launch director charlie
blackwell thompson hardly the only woman
in artemis launch control but in a sense
she's the woman it's going to change the
way in which we explore artemis ii
builds on what we learn in artemis one
and then artemis iii puts boots back on
the moon
on this test flight artemis will send
orion into a distant lunar orbit
reaching roughly 40 thousand miles
beyond the moon the most distant point
ever for a spaceship that can carry
humans the mission will last 42 days
before a splashdown in the pacific
like the sls rocket the stakes for nasa
are huge we gotta have a successful
flight before we put the astronauts on
the next mission otherwise you're not
putting astronauts on the next next
mission
for nasa today the moon tomorrow mars
discover resources and know how for
sustained living in deep space
after years of delays this new era of
space exploration starts with monday's
launch and in a couple hours nasa's
official countdown clock will start
ticking
dana all right mark straussman thank you
we look forward to it a cbs news
documentary on the nasa program artemis
america's new moon shot will run this
sunday 8 eastern on the cbs news
streaming channel or you can watch it
anytime on the free cbs news app